But yes,
but I would say it's still more hardcore
than the average place for sure. It's,
I mean that's that it is so open in in
terms of how people decide to structure
their camps.
Some people have very little sparring.
Like cowboy was telling me he
does he Harley's bars at all.
I mean he does just technical
work and pad work. He's like,
I already know how to fight. He wasn't
used to be completely opposite though,
right? Yeah. I used to spar, spar,
spar, spar and then we switched it up.
That's when he started doing much better
he said and he said it really made a
big difference because he was going
into fights damaged because you know,
he's such a,
he's so hardcore himself that sparring
with him ultimately must become more
hardcore cause just he's
such a fucking wild man.
Robbie Lawler did something similar as
one thing, but I think Tony Ferguson was
no sparring. Yep. Tony had no, no sparring
in preparation for his last fight.
That's when I saw him in
the post fight interview.
What makes sense about
that with him though,
is that he was coming off an
in catastrophic knee injury.
I mean he literally tore his ligament
off the bone and had to have it put back
on and then six months later he
was fighting. That's incredible.
This is not a whole lot of human beings
like back guy. Yeah. He's a real freak.
That level of grit determination to come
back from that injury and to perform
like he did the pedis. Yeah. That was
my favorite fight of the night. Yeah.
I really enjoyed it. I was bummed out.
The pedis hurt his hand cause his head is,
it's not going forward. No, he
doesn't mean he never gets tired.
That's the crazy thing about Tony.
You know an Eddie Bravo does his camps
with them up in big bear and he says it's
nuts, man. They do hill sprints,
everybody else's exhausted and Tony's
just lapping them this running back up.
I mean he's just never added gas.
He,
he'll work out six hours hard a day.
And on top of that,
what he does is he gets there, they rent
a house and then he builds his own gym.
So they'll have like a
house that they rent.
He'll Matt up the living room and then
he'll go outside. He'll put up a wing,
Chung dummy, don't hang heavy
bags. He does it all week check wt.
Yeah man mean he, he actually use
wing Chung and the fight with Pettis,
he trapped his hand and
hit him with an elbow once.
And I remember watching it going like,
Holy Shit,
he just use wind Chung inside the cage.
Like it works.
Like if you really know your shit,
he trapped his hand and then came right
over the top with an album and I went
look at that shit cause he's
always practicing it. You know,
he's always practicing Kung Fu
but he's a very, very unusual guy.
Like there's all this talk about a Connor
rematch because financially that would
be a fantastic fight, right? Financially.
But when you look at what happened,
that was a dominant victory.
I mean there was one round where
Connor did pretty good the third round.
Other than that could be
just sort of dominated him.
I mean dropped him in the second,
beat the fucking shit out of him in the
fourth and the third was around where
Connor did pretty good because
most of it was standing up.
I think he won that round,
right?
That was at the first round game you've
ever lost. Yeah, I think there was. Yeah.
But I mean it wasn't the one it like
running away. It wasn't like that.
He blasted him in the body, had him
hurt and there was nothing like that.
It was just the edge to him.
It's hard to make, I mean,
I guess you could say that's the same
thing that's sort of happened in the Nate
Diaz fight. Then Connor came back and
won the rematch. So this is the argument.
The argument is Connor was Rusty's
advocates for two years. He gets back in,
let's do a read and then
financially Jesus Christ,
I mean it was the biggest
fight of all time.
They're saying is above 2.4
million pay per view buys,
which is fucking bananas.
Yeah, that's, that's huge.
So if it's bigger than that,
and then they,
if they could talk people into a rematch,
I get it, but I don't want to see that.
I want to see Tony. I want to
see Tony, Tony [inaudible]. Yeah.
And the could be the suspension.
Let them give a little money to symbolic.
What's the one I might take on?
It would keep, you know, this,
the whole thing is fucked. It's not
professional. Right. It shouldn't happen,
but neither should people be fucking
screaming shit at him while he's fighting.
You know?
And,
and I guess that was going on the
entire time he was apparently having,
like Dylan Dennis was in Connor's
corner was screaming shit.
It could be while the fight was going
on, which I guess gets annoying. Yeah.
You said the new angle,
there's a new angle of video where
it could bebes Russian manager. Um,
as,
as Connor is tapping,
he comes right behind Dennis and slaps
him on the back like three or four times.
I did see that. Yeah. Kind of instigating
something. Yeah, there's that.
And then someone said could be a, that
Connor swung first, which is true,
but could be,
but already gone over the
cage and someone's going to
guide us coming at him and
Connor swung at him, but I think it
was already chaos at that point. Yeah.
You know,
it's all very unfortunate,
but what happened really
not. No one got hurt. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Connor got in.
Anybody down there? I mean, did you,
did you feel at all like,
oh man,
this rights coming towards me or
anything like that? Did it spread around?
I am so I'm so used to beat the shit
out of each other. It's like, oh,
now they're beating the shit
out of each other over here.
It didn't feel any more dangerous.
I was hoping the chairs wouldn't start
flying and then it wouldn't get too crazy
and I was really,
really,
really hoping that someone wouldn't do
something stupid and hurt someone to the
point where they would get kicked
out of the UFC or suspended.
But that might be the case with that
one gentleman. What does his name, Ba,
what is his name? And My fucking should
I should check my Instagram cause it's,
it's filled with free.
Zoomba
yeah. Can Be, it's like a training
partner. Yeah. I got fired.
I got fired.
His fight with the artist was supposed
to be with Artem and not a bad idea to
cancel that fight because it's so close
to this and obviously it's going to be
so, so charged up. Let
me find homeboys. Yeah.
They just moved to [inaudible] to fight
Michael Johnson, I think. Ooh. Hm. Uh,
there'll be a good fight for it. Yeah.
That'd be a real good fight. Yeah.